[Applause]
think about it
no we need 25 to make the country not
turn off the tv
[Applause]
now it's a match now steph pass the
thing okay
four or five of these at this money rack
he's still gonna get
15 with the mountain dew ball he's still
getting 31.
come on now let's see it 28
28. this see this is a heartbreaker for
utah
23 going to the last track
he's got to hit the ball no he doesn't
not all of them oh you can't miss now oh
he gotta make this gotta make
this all right
[Applause]
he got him he got it
yes i mean they went to the to the
bullpen and brought him out
and he went 28 and 27 to get to the
finals
but you're going to the greatest shooter
this game has ever seen man
yes and the guy i'll give it to to end
the game
gonna give it to him okay i'm gonna give
it to him
i'm still rolling with dane but okay
he turns uh 33 a week from today
does steph curry he beats 33 year old
mike connolly in the finals
of sweat dean 2021 mountain dew
three-point contest championship
stephanie curry from the golden state
warriors
lift it up hoist that trophy up
once again